well we know that it started in china in  a city called  wuhan the lockdown was expanded to 16  surrounding cities  a quarantine of 50 million people but  the outbreak is extending nonetheless  the number of countries reporting  confirmed cases growing by the day  in italia  europe is now the epicenter of the  global coronavirus pandemic  so  just like the millions of other  europeans work continues  but from home  setting up field hospitals is one of the  priorities of the new package of  emergency eu funds adopted by the  european parliament  the european commission struck a deal to  reserve three hundred million doses of  open 19 vaccines  m  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  correct  you